das ganze ist halt wie sein erdkugel das
heißt wenn ich jetzt hier quasi laufe
sieht das ganze aus die sonne erdkugel
das ist einfach richtig geil
löw meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem weiteren
minecraft video
ihr seht schon mit meiner welt ist
eigentlich alles in ordnung
ich habe ja schon mal letztes irgendwann
so ein video hochgeladen top fünf in
dieser top 5 serie topf mit minecraft
creepy shader und da war ja auch dieser
essay dabei da seht ihr ja das kann ich
selbst bestimmen in die richtung halt in
die ich hingucke hier ist es daher ist
es jetzt beispielsweise hier und es
dreht sich alles so behindert
sie fällt gerade oft das sogar wenn ich
in pausen menü wenn sich das ganze so
behindert da hinten wirbelt und so
jedenfalls kann ich halt hier die ganze
zeit hingucken und der fluchtpunkt hat
quasi wo ich hingucke bestimmtheit wie
ich das ganze dreht da sind dann auch
die schafe oder so da mops allgemein
wagten sich dann dass ein bisschen rum m
das ist nämlich der asset shader der ist
von hau mich tod keine ahnung wie sie
findet link zu dem etikett auch noch in
der beschreibung allerdings worum es
eigentlich geht
diese ab jemand der diesen fehler
gemacht hat hat einen neuen shader
gemacht und zwar in animal crossing
shadertakt mir neben rein so animal
crossing shader r5 und ihr seht schon
wenn ich hier so bin ist eigentlich gar
nicht oder so allerdings wenn ich unter
mich mal schaue oder halt auch in fünf
mal von umschaue wir schon das ganze
sieht so ein bisschen crazy aus erfragt
man sich etwas ist ja animal crossing an
diejenigen die es nicht kennen ist sonst
eines spielmachers so eine kleine figur
zieht in der stadt ein lernt er die
leute kennen und ist total friedlich und
alles und das ganze ist halt wie sohn
ehrt google das heißt wenn ich jetzt
hier quasi laufe sieht das ganze aus die
sonne erdkugel das ist einfach richtig
geil wenn die sprinter und so weiter
sieht man das halt auch es packt halt
immer noch so ein bisschen mit den hat
beispielsweise links und so das ist
alles total groovy und teilweise baut
sich auch die welt einfach total langsam
aus und wenn auf und wenn nichts mehr
geht es auch nicht so gut allerdings
lege jetzt beispielsweise da hinten sind
jetzt zum berg und wenn ich dann
beispielsweise mal hierhin lauf wenn man
denkt einfach ich befinde mich irgendwie
höher und wenn ich jetzt hier runter
springen würde dann würde ich da halt
runterspringen allerdings ist es halt
wirklich einfach so dass stellt quasi so
eine weltkugel für mich da dieses kleine
deges so weiter ich laufe desto
verwirrender ist das irgendwie weil man
sich denkt dass sich irgendwie und
reaper hallo man denkt sich irgendwie
dass man jeden moment runter fällt aber
letztendlich kommt es halt doch immer
wieder näher
weil es halt einfach so eine weltkugel
ist man denkt jetzt dahinter fall ich
dann erstmal runter bis ich wieder auf
der höhe bin aber dass ich alles somit
dreht ist es einfach richtig cool
gemacht sie zwar ein bisschen crazy aus
aber ich denke wenn man die szene
darstellen müsste ihm in seinem film
dann dreht man einfach die ränder
distance relativ
weit runter und dann kann man halt nur
so weit gucken wie das hier bald geht
und ja okay sind schon da oben diese
ganzen bugs ist naja dreht man halt die
ränder des uns ein bisschen drunter
läuft dann halt 100 wird da hinten
wirklich wieder so die welt neu um sich
herum kommen als wird man über so eine
richtig kleine weltkugel laufen also es
richtig heiß gemacht wir haben wir haben
ja auch eine schlucht adjamé gac racing
aus wie sich die schlucht links so um
die eigene achse drehte das ist
eigentlich auch schon das komplette
video für heute ich hatte nur gesehen
dass er halt diese nanny mit crossing
felder ausgebracht hatte und da hatte
ich mir gedacht ja komm da mach ich
jetzt nicht noch mal so einen update
top-5 shader video oder so sondern
stellt euch den einfach ganz kurz vor
kader nochmals ein paar tests machen und
zwar fliege ich gerade einfach mal nach
oben
ja okay es auch relativ sinnvoll und
zwar dass die welt dann einfach wieder
nach unten geht weil desto mehr ich mich
nähere desto mehr oh gott da ragen jetzt
diese bäume sogar so aus
gott sieht das crazy außer gott achtet
[ __ ] you you ist es krank wenn ich mich
rein theoretisch mal ganz nach unten
bauen würde würde man halt sehen
dot com der weg nach oben ist auch so
gebogen ja okay da ist ja auch logisch
aber hey ich fliege einfach nur nach
oben und ich flieg eigentlich so nach
unten so in die kurve rein
heavy cross das einfach außerdem muss
ich auf jeden fall immer weiter nach
unten ich fliege einfach nur nach oben
und es sieht so aus als würde ich in der
kurve fliegen oder so oder auch wenn ich
nach unten fliege alter wie krank sie
dass der ort wie durch sonne wasser oder
so damit kann man seine schwimmbad zähne
fließt oder rede ich endlich ganze zeit
von szenen drehen für seinen film gar
kein sinn luca das ist auf jeden fall
der animal crossing shader von dem
macher der auf den ace trader gemacht
hat es ist er fünf dort ihr findet den
download den link dazu et cetera alles
in der beschreibung natürlich lieber
verlinkt dann könnt ihr selbst mal
austesten
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob gott wie
ist das denn mit dem wasser achte faktor
sieht so eine welle die irgendwie hoch
kommen würde
das ist auf jeden fall der animal
crossing shader in minecraft ist kein
richtiger shaders halten wir so eine
modifikation ja ist schon schade war
muss die lsl shader vorher schon
installiert haben das ganze ding
hinzukriegen
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
dass videos recht kurz jetzt für heute
das ist halt einfach recht kurzweilig
heute es ist jetzt gerade 14 uhr und ich
habe auch heute wieder an dem buch
gearbeitet sehr sehr viel an dem buch
gearbeitet wir sind schon bei 160 seiten
in etwa ich habe mit anderen youtube
angesprochen ob die eventuell in dem
buch mit dabei sein werden
dort wird nämlich beispielsweise sturm
aber wird mit drin sein rot pilz und
noch ein paar andere youtuber also wir
haben da echt wirklich täglich neue
ideen was man in buchrain packen könnte
wären jetzt auch gedacht dass weder
eventuell noch mehr reinpacken wie genau
ich auf meinen namen und auf meinen skin
gekommen bin und allgemein auf die ganze
sache noch main kanal design was ich auf
so was alles wir haben da täglich neue
ideen wie man das ganze cool design
könnte deswegen bin ich deshalb wirklich
ich stecke meine ganze arbeit quasi
meine ganze motivation derzeit wirklich
in dieses buch das ist irgendwie cool
gilt weil ich will kein buch machen wo
ich nachher sagen dass ich unzufrieden
mit bin deswegen hoffe ich respektierte
dass das jetzt in dieser zeit mal nicht
so krasse videos kommen also dieses
video geht jetzt vielleicht fünf minuten
oder soll die stelle quasi nur scheider
frontlader ein bisschen ich hoffe das
geht klar eventuell gibt es auch bald
wieder ein neues projekt schon mal
schauen was da so was sich dafür ergeben
wird
ja darüber sonst würd ich sagen heute
ist ja mittwoch ich bin von freitag auf
samstag in hamburg und danach wieder an
der nordsee bis dienstag also da bin ich
auch wieder weg da werde ich der videos
produzieren mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
offtopic labern
ich hoffe einfach dass dort videos
passend kommen werden dass ich da noch
was aufnehmen werde
das ganze cool wird soll jetzt haben wir
den chaney mal wieder raus es ist schön
diese welt einfach mal so zu sehen ohne
dass dieser schilder mit am start ist
aber diese komischen bugs sind immer
noch da ja freunde wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen schreibt doch meine kommentare ob
eventuell noch denkt so ja das muss auf
jeden fall mit ins buch oder so oder
eventuelle ideen habe für videos oder so
ich hatte ja das habe ich gerade richtig
geschockt dass auf einmal diese welt auf
mich zu ich habe jetzt als video wieder
so sachen geplant natürlich stelle ich
euch commands vor aber ich habe auch
real live videos geplant und mal wieder
so ein paar gaming sachen also
irgendwelche spiele die ich zocke sowie
letztes den vormonat vor der kamera naja
was heißt gut an wurde sehr kontrovers
diskutiert diese sicht halte ich jetzt
endlich meine schnauze